Mất chứ thành chương đảng tổng sản Việt Nam, có hội nước cộng hà sợ ở Trung nghĩ Việt Nam,
chứ tính nước cộng hà sợ ở Trung nghĩ Việt Nam, chính phủ nước cộng hà sợ ở Trung nghĩ Việt Nam,
vì bán chương mặt trận tụ cua Việt Nam và ra đẹp vô cùng thức báo tin.
Đồng chi trình đức lường, muen ở bên bộ chính trị, muen chứ tính nước cộng hà sợ ở Trung nghĩ Việt Nam,
muen chứ tệ khội đồng cua phòng và an ninh.
Xin ngày 1 năm thằng năm 1970, quế quán sả phổ khánh, phy et đức phổ, nay là thị sản đức phổ tình quảng ai,
phường chú tại số nhà 2 trọng chiếm mê tảm phủ vật phúc, phủ nữ dài, quận bà đình, thành phố hà đội.
Lồng chi tham gia cách mạc từ tháng 2 năm 1990 và đảng cuộc sản Việt Nam và ngày 12.
Đảng thằng người 2 năm 1990, quế viên mắt chấp hành trung đảng các quá,
năm 1970, tâm chính, quế vô chính trị quá, tâm chính, quế viên thử vụ vụ bộ chính trị,
quá tâm, phó chủ tệ khội đồng vụ trường, từ tháng 2 năm 1990,
đến tháng 7 năm 1990, mê hai, phó chủ tưởng chiếm phủ, từ tháng người năm 1990,
đến tháng 8 năm 1990, mê bầy.
Chú tích nước tổng hoa sảo ở trung ý Việt Nam, chú tệ khội đồng vụ phòng ăn nền, khoảng 1 mươi,
1 một, đại biểu cuối các khoảng bây, tâm, chính, sau 1 thời gian lâm bệnh nặng,
mặc dù đã được đầm nhà nước, tập thể các sảo sự y bác sĩ tận tình cụ chữa,
ra đình hết lòng chăm sóc, nhiều sợ tự cao bệnh nặng, đồng chi đặt từ trên,
hồi 2,5 năm mê mốt phút, ngày 20 năm 2020, tức ngày 20 năm, tự năm 1980,
tại nhà dương, phường thọt 5.5 tuổi.
Chồng hơn 50 hạt động cách mạng, đồng chi đặt có nhiều đón có tò lớn,
đối với sự nghiệp cách mạng về văn của đàn và của sinh tộc.
Đồng chi đựng đàn nhà nước, tạo thường hôn chương sau văn,
phía hiểu sống 15 năm tự đàn và nhiều hôn chương viên chương,
phần thường, sang hiệu cao quý khác.
Đồng chi mất đi là một tổng thất tò lớn, đối với đàn nhà nước,
nhưng sớt ta và ra quý đồng chi.
Để vào lòng tiếp tương và tự đồng chi trảnh đất lương,
măn chức thành chương đàn tổng sản Việt Nam,
của hồi nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm,
chờ tích nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm,
chính phủ nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm,
từ bán chung ương mà chạm tổng phía tâm,
quyết định tổ chức lệ tăng lộn chiếc, với nghề thức, quốc tăng.
Măn chức thành chương đàn cộng sản Việt Nam,
của hồi nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm,
chờ tích nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm,
của hồi nước cộng hà sau trung, mặt chạp tổng có phía tâm.
Tổng tắt tiêu sự đồng chi trên nước lương,
nguyên nụ quy vinh bộ chí trị,
nguyên chủ tịch nước cộng hà sau trung viên phía tâm.
Đồng chi trên nước lương xin ngày 1 năm,
thương năm, năm 1 chiến trầm bà về bây,
quảnh sả phổ khánh, vệ tức phổ,
này là thịt sả nước phổ, tình quả ngái.
Thường chủ tại số nhà hai trầm chỉ biết tảm phổ vạm phục,
phường liệu sai quận, bà đình, thảnh phóa nội.
Thầm dạ thích mạng thẳng hai, năm 1 chiến trầm,
năm 1 năm, bà đàn tức sản Việt Nam,
ngày 1 chiến thâm 12, năm 1 chiến trầm, năm 1 chiến trầm,
quảnh sình tục tắt, thẳng hai, năm 1 chiến trầm,
năm 1 năm, đến thẳng trịm, năm 1 chiến trầm, năm 1 năm,
đồng chi tập kết ra mình bắt, họp xơ tất kích thuật nghiệp chất,
mộ công thường. Thẳng người, năm 1 chiến trầm, năm 1 năm,
đến thẳng tảm, năm 1 chiến trầm, năm 1 chiến trầm,
đồng chi làm nhân viên kết thật trong các loạn đổi,
tìm kiếm thăm dò để chất, họp mộ tốt chung cấp nghiệp chất,
tảm thẳng. Thẳng trịm, năm 1 chiến,
đến thẳng 3, năm 1 chiến trầm, năm 1 chiến trầm,
sống tương, đồng chi lạm lỗi trường lội để chất mốn,
đoàn để chất thay người, mối thư chi đoàn, đổi để chất mốn,
quy bên vàn chất hành toàn thân nghiên, đoàn đột,
cuộc đe chất, chiến quyền,
thẳng tức, năm 1 chiến trầm, sống tư đến thẳng 3,
tâm mình chiến trầm, sống sống, đồng chi lạm loạn phó ký tật loạn đẹp chất thẳng người,
mối thư chi mộ, đến chi quy quy viên,
thẳng chính, năm 1 chiến trầm, sống tư,
đến thẳng 1, năm 1 chiến trầm,
đồng chi lạm, lốc trường lốc trường tư thẳng rõ,
ca mối mộ tài hật mộ đẹp chất,
đảng quy viên là trường, mối thư loạn trường,
năm 1 chiến trầm, sống 1 chiến,
thẳng 2, năm 1 chiến trầm, mối mô đẹp,
thẳng tạm, năm 1 chiến trầm,
đồng chi lạm phó ký tường cuộc bản đồ đẹp chất,
đảng quy viên, quy viên thường vũ đảng quy cuộc bản đồ đẹp chất,
và thẳng 5 chiến trầm,
đồng chi lạm, đến thẳng 5 chiến trầm, mối mời,
đồng chi hi học trường, vết ai Quốc trung hần,
làm vĩ thư chi mộ lốc,
thẳng 5 5 chiến trầm, mối mời, đến thẳng 7,
năm 1 chiến trầm, mối bi chính,
đồng chi lạm phó l因 đoạn trường,
quyền l因 đoạn trường, l因 đoạn bản đồ đẹp chất,
đồng cuộc đẹp chất,
Mỹ thư đảng quy viên đoạn,
quy viên bản trầm,
đồng cuộc đẹp chất,
đồng tuung đoạn Việt Nam,
thẳng 5 chiến trầm,
mối bi chính,
đến thẳng 5 5 chiến trầm,
tảm vi bài,
đồng chi lạm,
tầm cuộc chiển,
đồng cuộc đẹp chất,
Mỹ thư bản cán sự đảng tuung cuộc,
hặc lấp,
của lịch kiến tế,
muốn thẳng tại Việt hạm lâm kiến tế,
Quốc trơn,
liên số 5,
chiến trầm,
đại diện thường trực nước cộng qua sau chúng ở Việt Nam,
tại hộn đồng tương trợ kinh tế,
S.A.V.
tại đây hồi đại biểu tọn Quốc lần thứ bầy của đảng,
thẳng 6,5 chiến trầm,
đồng chi tiếp tục được bầu là quy viên quan trách hoành trung đảng,
thẳng 7,5 chiến 2,
đến thẳng 8,5 chiến trầm,
đồng chiến lạm phó thu tưởng chính phủ nước tộng qua sau chúng ở Việt Nam.
Tại đây hồi đại biểu tọn Quốc lần thứ tảng của đảng,
đồng chiến được bầu vào bàn chấp hành trung đảng,
đồng bàn chấp hành trung đảng,
bầu vào bộ chính trị,
thẳng 6,5 chiến trầm chỉ vì sấu,
thẳng 8,5 chiến trầm chính bầy đến thẳng 7,5 chiến lạm,
đồng chiến lạm chủ tịch nước cộng qua sau chúng ở Việt Nam,
chủ tịch hội đồng Quốc phòng và ninh,
thẳng 9,5 chiến trầm chỉ vì bầy.
Ui viên thường bộc chính trị,
thẳng 8,5 chiến trầm chỉ vì tảm,
tại đây hồi đại biểu tọn Quốc lần thứ chính của đảng,
lồng chiến tức tục được bầu vào bàn chấp hành trung đảng,
được bàn chấp hành trung đảng,
bầu vào bộ chính trị,
thẳng 7,5 chiến lạm một.
Lồng chiến lạm quy bên bàn chấp hành trung đảng,
các quả, 6,5,5,5 chiến,
quy bên bộ chính trị, quả tảm chính,
quy bên thường bộ chính trị, quả tảm,
phó chủ tịch hội đồng một trưởng từ thẳng 2,
5,5 chiến trầm tảm với bầy, đến thẳng 7,5 chiến trầm 7,5.
Phó tổ tiến chính phủ từ thẳng 11,
5,5 chiến trầm, 7,5,
đến thẳng 8,5 chiến trầm, 7,5,
chú tịch nước cộng vào xấu chúng ta đến nằm.
Chú tịch hội đồng cúp phòng và ninh khoảm người,
khoảm người một.
Đại biểu có khỏi các khoảm,
bầy, tảm, mười, mười một.
Lồng chiến nước nàng nhả nước trong hiểu theo chế độ từ ngày 1,3 một.
Năm hành hình là tảm.
Zor có công lao tò lưỡng đặc biệt xuất sắc.
Lồng có vào sự nghiệp cách bạm của đảng,
và của rất tổ, lồng chiến đảnh được nàng nhả nước,
tạm thường hướng chức sau vang,
huy hiểu sống lâm năm tự đàn,
và nhiều hướng hướng, huy chương,
phần thường, dành hiểu cả huy khác,
bởi vì nâm và của tế.